a man who has given us so many thrills
for so many years on the ice Olympic
gold medalist from 1984 an author of
Finnish first winning changes everything
good to see you Scott hate to see you
this is awesome what a great space
thanks man
fantastic I appreciate that an upgrade
from the OAS PN days it's been a while
no I know I know I think that's when we
first met it had to have been yeah I
mean I always said just hang out there
all the time cuz we would rehearse Stars
on Ice in Simsbury and I just you know
on Sunday afternoon watch the games the
boomer and TJ and just hang out and fun
years great years now and then and now
here we are sitting here in in 2018 what
year is it I know what year is it so
finish first let's talk about this right
off the bat your book when winning
changes everything what do you mean by
that well it's just you know I really
see people just you know sort of like
looking for direction you know it's it's
how do I you know how do you know how do
I do anything how do i you know launch
how do i you know meet goals how do i
you know find my purpose how do i do
things you know in a time where we've
had kind of this participation trophy
mentality for a long time it's just you
know people get paralyzed now by failure
by criticism and looking for a path
forward so I kind of had a lot of really
lean years those years where I kind of
came in dead last a lot and failed a lot
of that you know the skating test when
was that oh that was early on you know
my first Nationals was you know I go to
73 and I fell five times in my program
and came in dead last and that was about
the best I had back then and so I
figured if I could find my way out of
that and if I could you know come up
with all different ways of surviving you
know cancer and all that you know those
setbacks said you know I might be able
to share some of that or a lot of that
in a book that could you know really
help people and so finish first is about
really just finding your purpose and
then here's how to kind of get to that
point where you're really living a
victorious life know
let before we I guess let's talk about
the cancer part of this phrase you're
currently battling your third brain
tumor yeah yeah can you see it no I
yeah that's good it's shrinking you just
the way you said that I gotta be honest
with you it's a little it's a little
jarring so I kind of gotten used to this
now it's kind of like just part of you
know everyday life for me is just what's
going on with my health and so I you
know first brain tumor diagnosed 2004
Gamma Knife radiation 2010 came back was
six years later and that was surgery
that kind of had a few complications and
then six years later it came back and
this time I just sort of tapped the
brakes and said let's just keep an eye
on this thing because we caught it
really early okay and and I just had
this instinct you know just to get
strong just get strong get strong I
don't know if it was physical mental
emotional spiritual what just get strong
and so I spent the last you know a
couple years just getting as strong as I
can be you know physically mentally
emotionally and spiritually and I know
Stuart Scott did that when Stuart was
diagnosed with cancer and you know he
and you know you go way back with him
and I bet I bet we've all at some point
we've definitely all three of us hung
together I wish I could have a
photographic memory like that but so
Stuart did Stuart worked out I mean he
got rock yeah rock song I'm not like
that you know Stuart say but um you know
I'm just really just trying to try to do
everything I can in my time and you know
the book is a big part of that just
taking everything I've learned and just
trying to help people kind of get off
the bench anything is it true that your
tumor has shrunk without medication the
last two the last two scans it's it's
shown remarkable yet diminishing and you
know it's wild is they can't really
explain it it's against the nature of
that brain tumor to ever do anything but
grow
and so even my endocrinologist is you
know she had the same tumour same
surgery same everything when she was 14
and became an endocrinologist because
she was underserved right and I go have
you ever heard of one shrinking she has
never you know I did the dr. Oz Show and
I said yeah have you ever heard of a
cranial shrinking nose never okay well
thank you yeah yeah I gets all the glory
on this one and for whatever reason I
don't know I've said a goodbye to a lot
of friends who have suffered through
cancer and and I get this really this
kind of pass and so I've been really
just working hard to you know just serve
so I don't I know I know there must be
scores of people watching listening to
Scott Hamilton that's saying well what
did you do well I did a lot cleaning up
my diet I took out a lot of things that
I knew weren't gonna help me out I hate
to say those on a show where you might
have sponsors okay yeah yeah but I went
to a high pH water which is really great
just because if I can change the
environment of my body from acidic to
more alkaline than cancer cells don't
like that very much so there's a lot of
research being done on that right now
about creating an alkaline environment
your body put gave up sugar gave up you
know just a lot of things that I knew
work and help me out well unless you
anything it wants your brain I'm not
gonna that's about to say unless you
gave up a hondo a Sleep Number bed wiper
blade or TrueCar or whatever you can
mention it because then we don't have
those no so I gave up anything anything
that would help the tumor I just quit it
and I added other things like
supplements and some things that you
know kind of just help Scott Hamilton
here on the Rich Eisen show and then I
couldn't help but hear you mentioned how
we are in a trophy everybody gets a
trophy culture right now and to me part
of the reason why everyone's like the
you know it's the the participation
trophy era is maybe people think that
you know what
life's too short like give it give a kid
a trophy and
so it's interesting to hear we've had a
conversation about life is too short and
yet you think that there's some
accountability in the parts of you know
I think sports are character and
physical development that's it it's
character and physical development by
taking out the character part you know
it to me it's like it's it's like half
doing it my example my son ten years old
just took up hockey last year he's
starting to play you know youth league
hockey see grind her in the corners oh
man he's tough he wants to check so bad
it's like no I check in your head but
you will be you just said you know he
lost his first two games they got killed
I mean they got destroyed and he got in
the car and he was really mad and really
upset and he goes I don't like losing
and it's and it's like oh I don't like
losing either I go I understand that
it's just um can we talk about this a
little bit you're sure I go what did
what did you learn today what did you
what you know why you guys lost and he
said well I mean I I need to scale a
little bit faster and I'm I need to work
on my stick handling and I got to get my
shot up I got to get my shot stronger
and I want to hit that corner you know I
just wanna get up there that's getting
the best yeah and I just said that's
great that's really cool what would you
have learn if you won and he went I
don't know you know precisely no we've
got to grow we've got to learn we've got
a experience we got to do all these
things and by making an enemy of failure
or losing and I just call failure
information tell yours just feedback
failure as it has no it's you know and
we avoid it like the plate I don't want
to fail I don't want to do I don't want
it will why not I mean it's just if we
can make a friend of failure
I estimated in the book that I've fallen
on the ice forty one thousand six
hundred times its speed it for thirty
six years right sure so if I felt three
times a day
you know it's ish so I figured um I
probably fell a lot more than that I got
up forty one thousand six hundred times
you know I can't sir fear was
extraordinary but I learned it was a
process like anything else it's just a
process and if we can learn to embrace
whole process and not just some of it I
think we're gonna be a lot better off so
in the whole mentality of finished first
is you know failure is just a part of
the process it's it's a learning
opportunity its information same with
critics you know I spent a whole chapter
on editing your critics and it's like
edit your critics you don't diminish or
delete or you know unless it's opinion
if it's opinion you have you know
absolutely the right to delete if it's
fact then you go oh okay now we have
something to work with here and so I try
to you know really give people um
strengthen character like I did a speech
for this leadership group for you know
universities and and when I said
failures information it was like I never
thought of it that way and you know when
I said edit your critics I put up mean
tweet after mean tweet after mean tweet
after mean tweet from the Olympics and
to see these young people go oh my god
they were like it's like dad I go what
who cares I go they would never say it's
my face ever I mean it's really fun to
write this stuff on Twitter and just
blast somebody but it doesn't it doesn't
mean a thing to me and I don't want it
to mean a thing to you either it's it's
just stuff if it's opinion or but
somebody just be mean delete it it
doesn't has no power and so I see a
whole section of our our society that
are just almost like now come come
through this cycle of you know we're
gonna no we're not gonna allow you to
feel this or feel that or endure and in
it and they're paralyzed now cuz life
comes at you hard and you need to be
prepared and I think the earlier we
could prepare our kids and even later in
life there's a lot of stuff we want to
get to have you clean out your garage
lately
I moved two years ago and it was really
tough for me to do ya guys so difficult
once you did once I did you felt great
what did you throw out
I just everything what was the toughest
thing for you to throw out oh man just
yesterday it was like third grade
homework yeah I'm serious
my mom is a pack rat she saved
everything and then and then I think she
instilled that in me yeah you know you
right now my seven-year-old is bringing
home homework with the big smiley face
on it I look at my wife and I'm like how
do you throw that away right yeah that's
hard but you know I figure with my
health history I'm just saving my kids a
lot of trouble finish first winning
changes everything here with Scott
Hamilton before I let you go I've got
Adam rip on here tomorrow what am I
gonna learn about him that I don't
already know you oh man he's just taking
this Olympic opportunity and he just
wants to build something great he wants
he's so hungry
he's so ambitious he just wants to build
something and I'll be really curious
I'll watch I want to see what he has to
say
I just saw my Jess Cagle and he was
talking about building a career and and
you know going into what's next and you
know I think he wants to just take
Ellen's spot you know I just do a talk
show so good guy I've known as since he
was 11 years old and I've seen all these
kind of skaters growing on him and he's
he's really he's a good person and he's
just right now he's looking at this
Olympic opportunity going mmm now let's
go yes I just stick the landing stick
the landing and let's make something big
out of this opportunity what is the
state of men's figure skating in this
country evolving you know when you've
got Vince and Joe who's at the World
Championships right now Nathan Chen
who's changed the sport I think you know
US men's you know skating it's it's
evolving I think you've got a couple
guys at the top that can compete with
anybody in the world and you got a lot
of juniors coming up that are looking at
these guys going I gotta be able to do
that yeah it's good to work well it's
great to see you
congratulations and all your successes
thank you so much it's very nice of you
to say that but you're one of the nicest
guys I've ever come across as are you
Scott Hamilton New York Times
bestselling author Scott Hamilton by the
way gold medalist Scott alloted finished
first winning changes everything check
it out right now in bookstores and
online near you thanks so much Scott
it's a book about everybody else not
about me yeah I'm the guide but this is
for everyone I think in all honesty I
think you know everybody here is
definitely picked that up because of
what you were you know how you were
saying and how you go about your
business and how you want others to
learn from what's gone on with your life
of immense success and obviously a lot
of
roadblocks to say the least yeah I
haven't but of all the things that you
said that's definitely stuck with me as
you've fallen forty one thousand six
hundred times and you got up each and
every damn time and that shows you law
what choice do we have
it's well that's true but some people
would stay on on the ice though they
finished first winning changes
everything but Scott Hamilton the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience